[SPEAKER_00]: What is up everyone? Welcome back to Paragliding Atlas podcast. I am Anindar Singh and if you are new here, this is the show where we talk about
[SPEAKER_00]: all things paragliding. From gear tips to flying techniques and stories to experiences. We cover some of the most interesting and
[SPEAKER_00]: important topics that you have always wanted to know more about from the blue yonder. Today, however, I want to chat about something that is
[SPEAKER_00]: crucial for all of us who love to fly. And I'm talking about none other than our humble carabiners. You know, those small metal clips that keep
[SPEAKER_00]: us connected to our wings, which we rely on every time we take to the skies? But how much do we really know about them? Let's take a closer look
[SPEAKER_00]: and see how we can make sure that they are safe and reliable as we practice the art of flight. So as I was designing this episode, I reached out to a
[SPEAKER_00]: trustworthy equipment manufacturer in our industry, which goes by the name of Finsterwalder and Charlie. Now, Finsterwalder and Charlie
[SPEAKER_00]: have often been known to make high quality carabiners for various applications in the sport of free flights over many years. But Thomas
[SPEAKER_00]: Finsterwalder, the owner of the company himself, could not be a part of the show due to his limited English language proficiency. However, he
[SPEAKER_00]: was kind enough to send me a research paper that he had worked upon a few years ago from which I was able to take some very key takeaways and
[SPEAKER_00]: prepare the first of its kind solo episode for all of you out there. Now, even though I completely understand that the world of carabiner is much
[SPEAKER_00]: larger to cover in a single episode, this, however, is an attempt to cover one of the most important, yet one of the most overlooked topics of
[SPEAKER_00]: material fatigue. Today we'll try to simplify some technical concepts, share some insights from the paragliding community,
[SPEAKER_00]: discuss some practical maintenance tips, and highlight why it is so important to pay attention to these small but vital pieces of
[SPEAKER_00]: equipment. So without further ado, let's get started.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's begin this episode by acknowledging that there have been some incidents in our community where carabiner failures have often led to
[SPEAKER_00]: serious accidents. While specific details are often kept confidential out of the respect for those involved, these unfortunate
[SPEAKER_00]: events serve as a stark remainder of the importance of regular equipment inspection and maintenance. And material fatigue and
[SPEAKER_00]: corrosion have often been identified as contributing factors in some of these cases. Most of the time they involve carabiners which are used
[SPEAKER_00]: beyond their recommended service life or without proper inspection and care. These incidents underscore the critical need to understand
[SPEAKER_00]: how and why carabiners fail even when they appear to be in a perfectly good condition upon visual inspection. So what exactly is material
[SPEAKER_00]: fatigue and why is it so crucial for us as pilots? To explain this further, I would want you to imagine a paperclip, something as simple as
[SPEAKER_00]: that. And if you keep on bending a paperclip back and forth repeatedly, what really happens is that initial few times, it flexes without any
[SPEAKER_00]: problem. but over time it keeps on becoming weaker and weaker at a certain point and eventually snaps. Now this is the simplest way to
[SPEAKER_00]: visualize material fatigue. The progressive structural damage that occurs when a material is subjected to repeated stress cycles. In
[SPEAKER_00]: context of paragliding, every single launch, every single encounter of turbulence, or when we perform maneuvers, our carabiners are kind of
[SPEAKER_00]: going through the same stress cycles. Now, applying the same analogy of paperclip, once these stress cycles keep on repeating themselves over
[SPEAKER_00]: a period of time, they tend to cause microscopic cracks in the metal. Now, I understand visualizing microscopic cracks is going to be
[SPEAKER_00]: difficult, but the problem is while individual stresses may be well within the carabiner's capacity or the rated limit, the cumulative
[SPEAKER_00]: effect over a period of time can weaken its strength significantly. And that is why understanding material fatigue and how it affects our
[SPEAKER_00]: equipment is very essential to our safety. Now, as I was going through the research paper, I thought of having some conversation with some
[SPEAKER_00]: experienced pilots who shared their thoughts on this topic. One of the pilots mentioned in their early days they didn't really pay much
[SPEAKER_00]: attention to carabiners. They assumed, just like all of us, that as long as the equipment wasn't visibly damaged, it was fairly safe to use. And
[SPEAKER_00]: another pilot who's an acrobatic flyer pointed out that high stress maneuvers actually put a lot more additional stress on carabiners. And
[SPEAKER_00]: in fact, acro flyers make it a point to replace their carabiners more frequently than the usual cross-country flyer or the weekend flyers.
[SPEAKER_00]: And most importantly, they also try and keep a log of their flights and maneuvers to monitor the stresses placed on their equipment over a
[SPEAKER_00]: period of time. Now these insights highlight a common realization amongst a lot of us and that is even without visible signs of wear,
[SPEAKER_00]: carabiners can fail if not properly replaced or maintained when necessary. To illustrate this further, I would like to break down a
[SPEAKER_00]: technical concept and I'll try and keep it as straightforward as possible. Let's talk about static strength. Static strength refers to
[SPEAKER_00]: the maximum load a carabiner can withstand when a force is applied in steady and slow manner. In other words, application of a constant and
[SPEAKER_00]: unchanging load. For example, if a carabiner, as they usually are, is rated at 20 kN. If you look at any of your carabiner from your equipment,
[SPEAKER_00]: you can see it must be rated at 18 or 16 or 20 kAmp. Now, kilonewton is a unit of measurement which runs in thousands. So let's say 20 kilonewton
[SPEAKER_00]: means 2000 kilograms. And the carabiner is rated to not fail up till 2000 kilograms under static conditions. However, this varies differently
[SPEAKER_00]: in real life flying conditions when we are actually dealing with dynamic loads. And these forces vary greatly in magnitude and
[SPEAKER_00]: direction, and often suddenly at times. You know, visualize this. Think about hitting a turbulence and facing a massive collapse. And
[SPEAKER_00]: then the reopening is so violent that sometimes these forces on the carabiner can spike momentarily, exceeding the typical load limits
[SPEAKER_00]: experiencing during the regular flight. Now going back to our paperclip analogy, bending it gently in one direction may not cause any
[SPEAKER_00]: issues. But rapidly bending it back and forth accelerates the fatigue process. So similarly, dynamic loads also contribute to the material
[SPEAKER_00]: fatigue in carabiners in a very same way. Each stress cycle, even if it's below the carabiner's maximum rating, adds up over time. And this
[SPEAKER_00]: cumulative effect can weaken the carabiner, eventually making it more susceptible to failing. Now, manufacturers of paragliding equipment
[SPEAKER_00]: such as Petzl and Edelrid provide guidelines to help keep our gear in top condition. While specifics may slightly vary depending upon the model
[SPEAKER_00]: and the equipment number you have, there are some common themes which we can focus on. Firstly, the service life is a very crucial concept. Even
[SPEAKER_00]: though metallic equipment doesn't degrade in the same way as a fabric or a plastic in paragliding, the manufacturers recommend retiring
[SPEAKER_00]: carabiners after a certain period of time or the amount of use. And factors such as frequency of use and types of activities and
[SPEAKER_00]: environmental conditions can all influence this timeframe greatly. Secondly, regular inspections are essential. Before and after each
[SPEAKER_00]: flight we should check our carabiners for any signs of wear, deformation or corrosion or damage. There is often emphasis on proper
[SPEAKER_00]: maintenance and this basically in simpler words means cleaning the carabiner after they have been exposed to something out of the ordinary
[SPEAKER_00]: such as dirt or sand or salt water which comes down to drying them thoroughly before storage or lubricating the moving parts with
[SPEAKER_00]: appropriate products such as silicon based lubricants. Finally, the storage also matters up to a certain point, although this goes overall
[SPEAKER_00]: for the harnesses in general, but keeping carabiners along with the harness in a cool and dry place, away from direct sunlight, not leaving
[SPEAKER_00]: them in your car or out in the landing field for long will of course help extend the lifetime of our equipment and eventually enhance the safety
[SPEAKER_00]: in our skies while we practice the out-of-flight. Now, as we are talking about manufacturer recommendations, I would also like to bring in a
[SPEAKER_00]: detail about environmental factors and their impact on our equipment. Pilots who frequently fly in coastal areas or humid climates need to be
[SPEAKER_00]: particularly vigilant about saltwater, as the moist air can accelerate this corrosion and even on the metals that are generally
[SPEAKER_00]: resistant to rust. So for example, if you're flying around the coast, carabiners are exposed to salty, humid air, and this can eventually
[SPEAKER_00]: lead to corrosion if not cleaned properly. So it's very important to rinse carabiners with fresh water after such flights and dry them
[SPEAKER_00]: thoroughly before storage. And same goes for sandy or dusty environments which can cause abrasion and wear and tear eventually. So
[SPEAKER_00]: overall regular cleaning helps remove small particles that might grind against the moving parts or surfaces and cause more damage to
[SPEAKER_00]: these microscopic cracks that eventually develop while we are practicing some hygiene maneuvers. Although we might not always think
[SPEAKER_00]: about environmental factors but they do play a significant role in longevity and reliability of our equipment so being mindful of these
[SPEAKER_00]: conditions and taking appropriate care can make a big difference. Now moving on, I would like to address some common misconceptions that can
[SPEAKER_00]: often lead to complacency. The first one, which of course even I as a flyer have to go through a lot of time is that if it looks fine, it is
[SPEAKER_00]: usually safe. You know, because usually we visually inspect something in the first go and it's easy to assume if our carabiners show no visible
[SPEAKER_00]: signs of damage, they're kind of good to go. However, as talked about previously, the damage in carabiners happens at a microscopic level
[SPEAKER_00]: and isn't always visible during visual inspection except for the usual paint job or some bit of scratches that we might be able to watch out for.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, oftentimes I've seen, and this usually goes for people buying pre-owned equipment, that carabiners last forever if they're not
[SPEAKER_00]: involved in an accident. And needless to say, as mentioned earlier, regular stresses will accumulate over a period of time based on how much
[SPEAKER_00]: the equipment has been used by the previous owner. So carabiners do have a finite service life and using them beyond this period will increase
[SPEAKER_00]: the risk of failure greatly. Now third one and the last one is basically about steel carabiners because steel is much more durable and
[SPEAKER_00]: resistant to wear and tear than aluminium that is more common in our industry. However, we have to understand it is not immune to material
[SPEAKER_00]: fatigue and corrosion and they also require regular inspection and maintenance just like the other aluminium or alloy carabiners that we
[SPEAKER_00]: are most commonly using in our usual equipment. Now let's get on to some actionable steps that we all can take to make sure that we keep our
[SPEAKER_00]: equipment in top shape possible. One of the simplest things that comes to my mind is aluminum carabiners have to be replaced every five years
[SPEAKER_00]: according to manufacturer's recommendation, especially if you fly frequently. And on top of that, if you engage in acro flying or perform
[SPEAKER_00]: dynamic maneuvers such as wing overs or spiral dives, you might consider replacing them a bit more often. Thorough inspections also
[SPEAKER_00]: help a lot. Visual checks before every flight such as figuring out if the gate is opening or looking for cracks or deformation of corrosion helps
[SPEAKER_00]: a lot. However, detailed inspections periodically can take this a step further. Try taking a closer look using a magnifying glass or even
[SPEAKER_00]: better try having a professional qualified person inspect your gear. Now I can sum up this section that by incorporating these simple tips
[SPEAKER_00]: into your routine you can help ensure that your equipment remains reliable and safe and you can have the peace of mind that you want while
[SPEAKER_00]: you take to the skies. So staying updated with latest information from manufacturers and paragliding community is vital. Because
[SPEAKER_00]: manufacturers often release safety notices or updates based on their guidelines on new research and new findings. So subscribing to their
[SPEAKER_00]: newsletters or checking their websites periodically can help keep you informed. Additionally, engaging with fellow pilots through clubs,
[SPEAKER_00]: forums or social media also allows us to share experiences and learn from each other. And remember, knowledge is a powerful tool in
[SPEAKER_00]: enhancing our safety and the safety of people around us. Now, as I plan to wrap up this episode, I would like to talk a little bit about advancement
[SPEAKER_00]: in carabiner technologies and how it looks forward in time to come. And how it looks in time to come. Oftentimes, manufacturers are always
[SPEAKER_00]: exploring new alloys and composite material that offer high strength to weight ratios and build resistance to fatigue. These eventually aim
[SPEAKER_00]: to produce carabiners that are lighter and yet more durable. The gate mechanisms have been there for a while and in time to come the idea is to
[SPEAKER_00]: reduce gate flutter and help minimize the risk of accidental gate openings and eventually reduce the stress on carabiners during
[SPEAKER_00]: dynamic loads. Some carabiners are also planning to bring in the visual cues of featuring wear indicators which basically will alert you when
[SPEAKER_00]: the equipment is reaching its end of its service life or needs inspection. Although still in development, there are some talks about
[SPEAKER_00]: RFID tags or sensors into carabiners to try and track the usage and stress cycle. This technology one day could provide pilots with
[SPEAKER_00]: real-time data on their equipment and conditions. While these innovations sound really exciting, I would like to undermine that they
[SPEAKER_00]: do not replace the need for regular maintenance and responsible equipment management. So to bring it all together, here are some steps
[SPEAKER_00]: that you can take starting today. First of all, check the age and condition of your carabiners. Review your equipment. Refer to the
[SPEAKER_00]: manufacturer's guidelines for service and maintenance life. Secondly, educate yourself. Read the user manuals and safety notices
[SPEAKER_00]: from your manufacturer. Stay informed about new developments and recommendations in the paragliding community. Thirdly, implement a
[SPEAKER_00]: maintenance routine. Make this a part of your lifestyle. Do regular inspections and try and stick to them. Try and keep a logbook of your
[SPEAKER_00]: equipment's usage and maintenance performed as well, and not just about the flying hours. And lastly, engaging with the community,
[SPEAKER_00]: sharing your experiences, participating in discussions, workshops, and webinars will help a lot. And taking these proactive steps, you not
[SPEAKER_00]: only enhance your own safety, but also contribute to the culture of responsibility and awareness in the paragliding community as a whole.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, final thoughts to wrap this up. Material fatigue in carabiners is a very crucial issue that deserves our attention. While it might seem
[SPEAKER_00]: technical or even daunting at first, understanding the basics empowers us to make better decisions about our equipment. Remember,
[SPEAKER_00]: these little small pieces of metal are responsible for keeping us connected to our wing and keeping us safe. So respecting their
[SPEAKER_00]: limitations, maintaining them properly and replacing them when needed is the way we can entrust our lives to them in a responsible
[SPEAKER_00]: manner. And on that note, thank you so much for joining me on this journey into the world of carabiner safety. I hope you found this discussion
[SPEAKER_00]: insightful and it inspires you to take a closer look at your own gear. If you have any questions, thoughts or experiences that you'd like to
[SPEAKER_00]: share, please feel free to reach out to me at aninder at the rate paraglidingatlas.com To spell it, I'd say it's A-N-I-N-D-E-R at the
[SPEAKER_00]: rate paraglidingatlas.com and also all my social media links are available in the show notes below. And needless to say, your insights
[SPEAKER_00]: enrich the community and help us all fly safer.